the great thing about Hollywood is there
are always new romance rumors the latest
Ben Affleck is trying to work things out
with his wife Jennifer Garner wait a
minute no because the latest rumor is
actually that Ben is back with his old
flame Jennifer Lopez but either way
Manafort Lillian was it JLo just with
Drake look I know it's all really
confusing that's why Michelle Turner is
here to sort out all this Ben and Jen
business you also said that Ben was your
first heartbreak it was real it was my
first kind of heartbreak it was my first
like adult heartbreak was it because it
was so public and we wanted to know
every single thing about your
relationship didn't help you were about
to get married it didn't work out and it
was just a bad heartbreak one headline
says it's the return of Bennifer JLo and
Ben Affleck are back on and their quote
hotter than ever
click on the article and there's quotes
from an alleged insider saying the exes
are quote meeting in secret and she was
blushing when he kissed her in greeting
and there's so much chemistry between
the two pretty good gossip right well
there's just one problem
we are told none of it's true
[Music]
of course it's easy to see why many
would want to believe Bennifer 1.0 have
reunited after all Ben and Jennifer
Garner announced their split 20 months
ago but still haven't made it official
and JLo just said this there's another
rumor we wanted to bunk and it's that
bin has been so desperate to reconnect
with JLo he tried to cast her in his
latest film live by night but Jen garner
said no way again that one's false but
what about the report that Bennifer 2.0
Affleck and garner are calling off their
divorce well here's what we know first
they are quote diehard committed to
co-parenting what are your kind of areas
of expertise with the kids my areas of
expertise is the kids at spotty a source
close to the pair told us Ben still
lives on the same property with the
family and quote not one thing has
changed since their split was announced
they both have done things they're not
proud of and in no way was been a
shining husband but whatever this new
normal that they've created for their
family is they're doing it we are
definitely a modern family we are we're
doing really well Vicki and I are great
friends I want them to see you know
everything's okay
[Music]